i watched all the clips read all the
stories that's out there so i've seen
the good bad and the ugly about you
and
i see the love and hate relationship
there are those who hate you and i i
called some friends and these are guys
that are in business who are from
chicago
and i said tell me what you think about
this guy
and they said uh well let me tell you
who he is you know there are people here
that like him there are people here that
think he's innocent there are people
here that think he's guilty
but
it was a mixture it wasn't just all good
and all bad
some people that i thought were going to
be saying nothing but bad things about
you were like no this guy was actually
trying to do some stuff but he got
caught doing what everybody else does
and he went to jail for those the other
guys didn't and then some of the guys i
talked to they just said pat don't let
him fool you he's a you know charmer
charismatic this this that you have to
understand where he said he's a very
good persuader so
why this love-hate relationship with you
well isn't that the case when you take
strong positions i mean with all due
respect if if you were
not those things that means you didn't
stand for anything right franklin
roosevelt said ah you have enemies good
that means you stood for something and
uh you know i think as governor i was
the first democrat governor 26 years
elected in illinois but i didn't want to
raise taxes on the people my party loves
to raise taxes on regular people we
claim to be the party of the little guy
and working people but every chance the
democrats in illinois get they keep
checking up taxes that's why illinois is
the highest tax state in the nation so i
was determined to invest more money in
health care and provide health care to
kids and other families
do things like free public
transportation for our seniors which we
did preschool for three and
four-year-olds and a lot of other
initiatives without raising taxes on the
people which meant to pay for those
things you got to move the money around
that means you're taking it away from
others who benefited from it and when
you do that you piss them off so i think
a lot of it had to do with the
establishment came after me and you know
i sat in prison and watched
with horror
what the same people using the same
playbook were trying to do to president
trump and what they did to me a democrat
governor at the aaa level they tried to
do at the major league level to a
republican president fortunately he was
able to beat it because he had
you know a lot more support and he had
the ability of the oval office and the
bully pulpit that the president has that
governors don't have
but it's the same thing and this is very
scary for our democracy it's not a
democratic republican issue it's an
american issue it goes to the heart of
our freedoms we the people should choose
our leaders in free fair and honest
elections and not have them have the
choices taken away from us by corrupt
prosecutors who would criminalize legal
things i didn't break a single law and
yeah you have those naysayers over there
in chicago everything i did was legal
they were
conversations that began because
president-elect obama sent an emissary
to me to make a political deal about the
senator he wanted the person he wanted
picked his senator we discussed what we
could get in that political deal all
legal
i mean
i got to d in algebra i'm not claiming
to be the smartest guy in the room but
i'm not that stupid how do you [ __ ]
steal a senate seat when you're the
governor and get away with it you can't
be that stupid and you don't mind me
swearing right now you're fine you guys
are [ __ ] golden
so um but go back go back to that when
you're saying go ahead right so you know
they expected they what they did was the
prosecutors did they
they brought shock and awe i was roger
stone before roger stone in other words
they came to my house with swat teams at
six o'clock in the morning on the ninth
of december 2008 i'm a sitting governor
you don't arrest a governor or anybody
unless the person's threat to run away
or a threat to his neighbors i was
neither one of those things but they did
it for the big show and they did it to
create an environment where they create
this
inevitable foreseeable chain of events
that would invite the media to see the
super sensational story
and run with a narrative that they fully
expect that i would just give up and
give in and cut my losses and maybe take
18 months but i would never do it and
and so i fought back and they didn't
convict me the first trial they tried me
a second time they used an unlawful
standard to convict me on legal things
no one even alleges that it took any
money it was all politics and the
so-called sale of the senate seat which
i'm known for was reversed by the
appellate court on the 22nd of july 2015
as i sat in prison they could never
uphold that unlawful standard they used
against me but they kept me in prison
for three fundraising requests where
there was no quid pro quo which means no
crime but they moved the line and and
instructed the jury to convict if we
asked for campaign contributions from
people or groups who had business
interests with the state which is how
politics works completely legal but i
think it was such a big deal
that somebody had to go down and you
know when you're fighting back against
that kind of power
deep down you know you're going down but
you make a decision i'm going down
fighting because as winston churchill
said nations that go down fighting come
back but those who shamelessly surrender
don't
so i think uh i think i've got a big
powerful comeback ahead of me yeah when
you're saying
you know they did this they did that
they did this who is they
can you can you define is it michael
casey is it who who's they
well the u.s attorney patrick fitzgerald
who's real close with james comey these
guys worked together he was in the fbi
the number one number two guy in the fbi
mueller was the fbi director when they
arrested me it's the same people that
were doing the trump what they did to me
and i think president trump recognized
that and that's among the reasons why he
sent me home
and uh what was his reasoning though
because he didn't have beef with you
to start there must have been something
you have done where he said uh
something's up with that guy where did
this all initiate
you know i learned as after i was
arrested i learned that they had been
investigate first of all i knew they
were investigating my administration and
me
since the very beginning when i became
governor within six months for what
reason though they were looking at some
people that that i was close to a guy by
the name of tony rusko who was close to
obama and me raised money for both of us
and uh but i had nothing to do with any
of the things that they were looking at
him at but i was well aware that they
were looking and you know you come out
of chicago politics you just assume
those people look at you
so everything you know
i tried to do was to make sure we were
super careful we didn't do anything to
cross lines the irony is those fbi tapes
for six weeks they were taping me
i assumed it was possible they could be
listening
i was discussing the sale of sentencing
i was talking about every possible idea
so that whatever we did was legal didn't
cross lines and was the best possible
decision i could make on something that
was effing golden it was [ __ ] golden
you got this thing and everybody wants
it and you can make a real good
political deal that could be helpful
hopefully to people if you do it the
right way so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you